un carême vous c'est l'un des vôtres un
verger yannick jadot qui portait le
texte au parlement pour taxer en effet
les produits importés les plus polluants
vous êtes abstenu
pourquoi parce que dans le texte que
nous avions présenté moi j'étais le
rapporteur des verts dans deux
commissions la commission industrie
énergie et la commission économique et
c'est effectivement yannick jadot qui
portait le texte dans la commission envi
environnement et on s'est abstenu parce
que on est d'accord sur le mécanisme on
l'appelait de nos voeux cette forme de
protectionnisme vert parce qu'il ya une
urgence climatique aujourd'hui et donc
il faut absolument mettre des règles en
place pour obtenir cet objectif de
neutralité climatique en 2050 et les
moins 55 % en 2030
ça va être demandé des efforts mais il
faut protéger aussi notre industrie à
qui on demande de faire des efforts des
importations extérieur et on ce qu'on
avait proposé nous dans le texte c'était
parce qu'on a déjà un système des
changes carbone au niveau européen
le thé est ce qu'on a pu on appelle ça
on a déjà un marché carbone européen est
ce qu'on souhaitait nous c'est la
disparition dans ce dans ce marché
carbone européen en date ce qu'on
appelle des quotas gratuits des droits à
polluer comme on les appelle
vulgairement parfois la disparition de
ses droits à polluer en fonction de la
mise en place de ce mécanisme
d'ajustement carbone aux frontières
est ce qu'on l'avait obtenue dans la
commission envi tous les groupes
politiques avaient apporté leur soutien
à cette à cette orientation là et il ya
un amendement qui a été déposée le jour
du vote en plénière au parlement
européen qui a réintroduit
les quotas gratuits et qui a été adopté
à 10 voix près sept amendements au
parlement européen donc voilà ce que
nous on était d'accord sur le texte on
était prêt à le porter comme comme
d'ailleurs on avait réussi à faire un
peu un consensus au sein de la
commission envi mais cet amendement là
nous nous a fait nous abstenir parce
qu'on ne peut pas maintenir et
d'ailleurs on verra ce que
l'organisation mondiale du commerce on
peut pas maintenir une sorte de dead à
ces quotas gratuits à l'intérieur de
l'europe et biens importés chacun enfin
et taxer toutes les importations carbone
sur le marché européen
[Musique]